Hey chicos ver esto. Estoy en el centro de la cultura polinesia en la isla de Tahití
Y estamos aquí pescando y tienen pequeños anzuelos de pesca que hacen de los clips
Pero se les acabaron los clips, por lo que [estaban] tratando de Jury-Rig nuestro propio con un soda Tab ahora
No se si esto va sebrier
Pero creo que podríamos usar un poco de masa de pan
Y ponemos la masa de pan en este pequeño gancho que
Hice que pudiéramos ser capaces de atrapar a nosotros mismos un pez vamos a ver si funciona
Yo sólo uso algunos recortes para cortar un punto muy agudo y tomar algunos de esta masa de pan
Vamos a repetir eso
Haz que se parezca a un poco de forma de gusano y luego ató un poco de pesca [línea] en allí
Lo vamos a sumergir en el agua y ella bleep cualquier cosa. Oh
Dios mío en la primera. [Oh] que casi tenía en el primer intento. Rompí mi soda Tab
Yo estaba tratando de doblar el gancho, y lo rompí
Y he estado en todo el parque buscando todas las latas de basura aquí
Ellos no venden latas de refresco de todo el mundo tiene botellas de agua y botellas de soda
Sólo encontré esta ficha de una taza de fruta, así que creo que vamos a ser capaces de hacer un trabajo
Es un poco más amplio, así como va a cortar esta cosa y ver que podemos ver
Ahora envuelvo esto en mi muñeca sólo para
Evitar que se enreden y
Lo amarré a mis dedos ahora. Tengo que hacer es tomar nuestro pequeño gancho hobo y tirar en el agua como que
Whoa comprobar hacia fuera [su] trabajo para trabajar para trabajar?
No es un pez muy grande. Sin embargo, tenemos un pez. Mira eso. Sí. Sí, hiciste [aquí] vamos
Solo saca esta pequeña cosa. Eso tiene un pequeño gancho. [Uh] allí. Vamos a mirar
Aquí vamos a sostener en espera en espera en espera en mirar a ese tipo que tienes un pez
Wow, he's fast
Eso es genial
Mi hijo pequeño en realidad cogimos un pez muy grande con un [clip] y sólo un poco de masa de pan para que te va a trabajar
Sosténgalo desde abajo
Eso es asombroso que es amigo hermoso. Correcto, devolverlos
Ahora honestamente en nuestra experiencia utilizando paperclip parecía trabajar mucho mejor
Somos mucho más consistentemente atrapados mucho más peces usando clips
Pero las lengüetas de la soda trabajarán en una pizca [allí] usted va allí usted va
sí que aparentemente se puede usar una lengüeta de soda y un poco de masa de pan y coger el pescado
Es mucho más fácil de lo que esperaba que iba a ser truco realmente genial
Aprendí aquí en la isla de tahiti [en] el centro cultural polinesio. Muchas gracias por unirse a este video chicos
Te veré la próxima que te hable entonces
Oh, eso no es delicioso. Oye, deberíamos ir a buscar la tapa y abrir esta huh sí
Tu/usted